we've got Luke P trying at emotions I
want to move mountains for you
we've got sad Peter this sucks
and we've got lots of Chris Harrison I
know this might seem a little unusual
this is your episode six recap of Hannah
brown season of The Bachelorette grab
your glasses it's time for roses and
Rose a hi everybody I'm Lauren Zee my
wearing hoods let's start off back with
the end of lucan Hannah's date oh my god
so Luke and Hannah are still talking I'm
not even wearing a watch but they are
still talking they're talking so long
that watches have been discontinued and
are no longer and he's on this planet
they're talking so long but now we just
all have a chip built into our wrist
that tells us what time it is okay so
they're still talking confused right now
and Hannah is kind of saying like this
is not working out dude I don't think
that there are any words that likely do
what I want
I think it's hitting Luke wait a minute
this is actually not working out and he
tries to own everything by saying my bad
I screwed up my bad and I burst out
laughing was this just me I mean I
couldn't take him seriously because his
understanding of the situation is just
so wildly different than Hannah's he
wants to take full ownership he says
flash it but of what let's move on like
Luke do you even know what you're taking
ownership of I certainly don't know but
even with all my frustrations I'm not
thinking Hannah's gonna send him home
because she seemed so into him and then
Hannah sends him home
Sam and I go home tonight
yes what what this show is a mystery to
me and I love it so much so Hannah is
sending Luke people and finally things
are picking up and I'm like oh my god
are gonna be moving forward from this
and oh my gosh there's gonna be new
storylines and drama this is so exciting
Luke he is walking away dramatically in
the woods and I need a Pfeifer because I
don't want to lose her
and that's something is nothing gonna
stop me nothing's gonna clutter or cloud
my mind nothing's going to stop me even
though he and I had just said I don't
want to give you a rose I just like want
you to respect that respect that shot
confused so he's saying these things and
then he's turning around through the
woods and he's coming back to Hannah and
I'm thinking oh my god is this going to
be the shortest breakup in Bachelorette
history this is my fault and it turns
out yes
okay so Luke and Hannah start talking
and I am getting emotional whiplash and
I believe he was gone in TV time for all
of two minutes that's what my personal
chip says and then I'm laughing again
I've screamed about this like it's
comical at this point isn't it these
interactions he tells her I'm gonna
stand over here
yes Dean are you for second
why cuz I want ya this is horriffic oh
my god what's he gonna say
and then he scream I hate this he says
he wants to scream and Lupe's screaming
is like I can't spit it I want to tell
you feel seriously I like you mountains
for you it's so it's so strange I
couldn't stop laughing what were you
guys thinking when you were watching
this ok back to the guys so Luke comes
back and says I didn't get a rose but
Hanna said she still wants me to be here
and I'm still here but I have to say
this stakes feel low to me here you know
Anna as insane chemistry with Luke peace
she has said the most chemistry with
Luke Pete you so got guys looking around
like grant Dustin Dylan Devin is there a
Dylan or a Devin he's a big-ass douche
canoe there's some other guys here still
and it seems very unlikely that Luke P
will be sent home over these other guys
who we haven't even really seen Hanna
interact with right did you believe that
Luke P was going to be sent home at the
rose ceremony let me know in the
comments below now considering that
Hanna is giving Luke his 999,000 point
to chance I do want to take a moment for
a lesson
just as Hanna tried to teach Luke P what
feelings were I want to do a quick
learning moment to remind us all of what
Luke peas qualities actually are does he
deserve this next chance from Hanna
welcome students this is Luke P 101 I'm
your professor lauren zima
I don't want an apple at the end of the
year bring me some wine okay
Luke peep professed love for Hanna after
knowing her for less than 24 hours I'm
genuinely starting to fall Luke feed
does not respect Hanna's time or
relationships with other people
Luke Pete doesn't respect what Hanna
says or wats just like one tater is like
that I don't want to go home Luke Pete
thinks he knows what's best for Hanna I
just don't see a fit for him not her
Luke belies blatant weight my man here
asked me on my behalf
dad's told Dean Luke P blames other
people for his actions
this is 100% carrots for Luke B cannot
communicate his emotions can somebody
talk to him about what it means when I
say how do you feel okay everybody
would you date Luke P there's only one
question on this test and there's only
one right answer it's a yes or no guys
it's not even a multiple choice and
there's no si all right we're moving on
to the cocktail party thank God have a
cocktail everybody we need a moment
don't we because we have been through
we are beaten down we are dying we are
drowning but the show is keeping us
alive with just a breath just a bit of
hope we are hanging on by a thread and
that thread is in the shape of Tyler C's
arms
oh the Angels have spoken and smiled and
come down for a moment knowing that we
were on the edge of certain death we get
Tyler see shirtless we get Peter smiling
and those things are like an injection
to the heart to wake us back up and
bring us around so he Anna shows up in a
cool car great think very glam very
escapist I need this yes and Jana tells
the guys she wants to get into it I want
to know like what's hard to share she
grabs her glass and says grab a tissue
I'm here to talk drama I want to know
about what makes you you from the
deepest parts of your pain but we don't
get that do we we start with Garrett and
nothing real is discussed and Garrett
brings up Luke peace so I know yet I
want to want to leave uh-huh Garrett why
after what she just said why Garrett why
weren't you listening
do I have to be screaming like pain I
want to move mountains for you it's like
a cartoon character before he left
Garrett talked to Hannah and tells her I
asked Luke P to not talk about any of us
on your one-on-one he said he wouldn't
did he and Hanna says well he did but
because I asked him she takes full
ownership of that she did say Mike's
name but I do feel like I provoked it
Garrett then stirring the pot with a
spoon the size of which I have never
seen turns around holding that spoon to
the other guys and says Luke P talked
about us Mike was the name that came up
Garrett
I appreciate you
she has to go into mom mode with them
like they are her children and she has
to scold them and punish them and
discipline them because they are acting
up stop I'm so frustrated about their
always being fights in the house
not cute guys and you know what these
are right now all of you I'm telling all
of you guys this these are boys on our
screens these are not men and I would
like you to be a man be an adult grow up
I wanted to let that comment sit for a
minute okay
poor Connor he just wanted a little
moment with Hannah but she had to yell
at everybody else he's just been
standing in the shadows the whole time
like uh Hannah I just wanted to talk to
you I'm tell you I was really in yeah
but you got a I got it y'all these other
guys though I got my great jacket on
whenever he arrived back and then my
heart sank forth from my body down
through the floor into the depths of
hell can we please just cut the guy I
feel like I have just been like not
speaking up or whatever just cuz I've
been so over this you're sweet
Peter it's not smiling anymore this
whole scenario has wiped the smile from
perhaps the happiest man I have ever
seen on reality television Peters speaks
on this scenario and says and I quote
this sucks
this sucks and you're right Peter it
does and it sucks that you think it
sucks because you don't think anything
sucks because you're so happy
that is where we're at everybody so
Johanna leaves and then she hears that
the guys are still talking and you know
what she's got a chugger champagne so I
just in solidarity here we go
it's disturbing to me how easy that was
that's what this honestly that felt
pretty on brand so he Anna chugs or
champagne finishes her glass because
girl has to go back in there
this war isn't over for her she's on
World War three now why are they doing
this to her and of course
Tyler gently touches Hannah on the back
of she leaves because he wants to say to
her girl I'm here for you and then he
speaks to the men because Tyler is the
voice of reason dr. Maya she's up here
crying you know what I mean because she
can't enjoy yourself here our last night
in Scotland is mm-hmm and that voice is
deep and grizzled and southern and
beautiful and again he is the breath
that I am holding
okay Hanna is crying and says she's mad
and side note to Luke Pete that's a
feeling that was Petty I contributed in
this and apologized all y'all gonna
apologize to Hannah wanna see her next
Garrett apologizes to the room and great
good job Garrett owning it Luke
feels the need to tell the room that he
appreciates Garrett's apology I will say
I personally appreciate your apology
because he didn't get the time with
Hannah that he wanted tonight I had
important things to tell her and I had
important questions to ask her and I
wanted to hear things that she had she
wants to tell me Hanna talks to Chris
Harrison true party party's over
by the way drink every time you see
Chris Harris in this episode he's
stirring responsible he isn't so much of
the episode the rose ceremony Garrett is
owning it hope that she forgives me for
ruining an evening
and Luke is blaming Garrett this is 100%
carrots for 100% not owning it at all
please so Hanna gives Luke P a rose were
you guys surprised because I wasn't
I thought she has to give Luke P arose
at this point hey cuz I do think she
still has feelings for him but B because
if she doesn't give him a rose then
she's essentially allowing the men to
dictate her future and she wants to make
it clear that she's calling the shots
here so she had to so goodbye
and now we're in Latvia
and Peter says it's south of Estonia we
are in Riga Latvia just south of Estonia
on the Baltic Sea this is a beautiful
city it's super romantic I'm sorry that
didn't help me I don't know I need a
globe
I just don't know or just a Google image
of the map I don't know where we are but
you know what the guys sit down and
they're in an outdoor cafe and so I'm in
and I love an outdoor cafe it looks
great there do I want to go too laughs
yeah I guess I love Latvia let's go what
is that roses and roses a group trip
shoot I'll go on a group trip together
should it be a cruise a cruise of just
rose' we go to Latvia I'm okay I
honestly just want to make sure you're
doing okay in all this so the editing
gets a little weird from here now Chris
and Hannah are talking on these blue
chairs we don't really know where but I
will say that the blue chairs really
brought out Chris Harrison's blue eyes
didn't think I need to because I'm so
stressed up at this episode
anyway by the way Hannah's hair looks
great that's all I have to say I'm just
taking every positive thing as a whim at
this point I'm like love to the chairs
great upholstery Hannah's hair no
flyaways Wow
we're outside drink for the silver
linings can I just have a one cocktail
party that doesn't go to crap so Hannah
is very lost
she is alluding to the damage in her
past and damaged four years which we
still don't know about I would love to
know about we don't know because the
guys haven't asked her as Hannah pointed
out there's been a lot of drama and
Hannah is in tears and Hannah's brow is
furrowed and I am worried for her I
don't know how this works for people I
thought I did I thought it did work
Hannah says she doesn't know if this is
going to work anymore and I don't really
blame her because it has all been so
much man which Chris Harrison told us in
the beginning of the season perhaps more
man rather than ever before
head to et online.com for many puppies
is our Bachelorette is going through one
of the most difficult times in her life
when things get funny because why is
Chris back at the mansion that's where
he is right I'm confused we were in like
a coffee shop in Latvia a commercial
break ago I don't know why he's in the
mansion it's very weird but he is there
and then he is doing another sit-down
with Hannah because we have to talk
through how Hannah can like not jump
over a fence and leave the show you know
Hannah did tell me the beginning this
season that she almost quit that she
thought about quitting anything check
out that interview and why you can't let
that happen okay I think there are some
things we need to get to the bottom of
they are sitting down I don't know if
they sit down in the mansion or in
Latvia here's this room candles gowns
why his hand on the gown is she about to
do rose ceremony at confused but what
did you guys think of this sit-down did
you like it did we need it I like to sit
down in Latvia because Chris Harrison is
a good interviewer and he gets people to
tears
look we do this sit-down in the mansion
Latvia I don't know and I'm reminded of
how everything has been about Luka
people and it doesn't seem like that's
gonna change guys because then we get
the trailer and now it's a special sneak
peek at the rest of the season love is
definitely in her hair
this was wild I was captivated did you
guys like the trailer so someone we
learned someone comes with a ring for he
went out kind of ring he demanded to see
you he's fully convinced that you are
his wife that you are the one my only
prediction can be Luke P Tyler is fresh
off of Baywatch in a red swimsuit
shirtless on top of Hannah
Red's my favorite color and you guys the
show is the gift that keeps on giving I
get my sailing date oh my god they goes
sailing Jesus is real by the way I think
faith is gonna become a very important
part of this show you can have detail on
that Comfort interviews about that yes
this is wonderful I'm so just I needed
this I needed like color and excursions
and everything then we find out Luke is
in love with Hannah I'm completely madly
in love with her and once wait until
they're married to have sex and I can't
wait to have sex with everyone when
they're not surprising but Danny
Hannah's goes naked bungee jumping we
have seen that moment before we've
learned it's with Garrett all right
and Luke says and I quote I want to make
sure that she's bleep around
not sleeping around I don't think she
would ever do that but yeah I got a I
got a make sure I want to make sure that
she does bleep around
[Music]
yeah so obviously Luke is going to be
the source of this conflict that we have
been teased about sex and religion and
the marrying of the two and I feel that
our feelings for Luke P are going to get
even more fiery I Wow my notes ended at
this point I got so frustrated you guys
look at this it says and Luke says let's
and how the marriage appear then I
stopped typing I don't know I can't even
remember now I'm so I'm so gone I don't
know what the rest of Luke said was
because I have gone off the deep end
watch as I dive in to a bottle of wine
that was this episode everybody
incredibly powerful I love you guys so
much thank you for watching we will be
here trying to survive thank you guys so
much for watching I'm on cameo if you
want a cameo please request me and leave
details because I love like writing
songs for you guys and doing fun stuff I
will do whatever you want me to do
because it's fun for me and I need some
fun of my life because Luke P has
dreamed of my joy be honest because
bleep around that's it let me know your
thoughts in the comments below love you
so much bye hey guys it's me I'm
vlogging because so much has happened so
much news today that we had to add it
onto roses and Rose a first of all
Lauren bushnell and Chris Lane are
engaged that is honestly so great so
happy for the both of them we recently
did a home tour with them if you want to
check it out of DTM like on shameless
blog and you know she seems really happy
he seems like he treats her really well
so that's great and who doesn't love a
Lauren and Chris combo you cannot go
wrong in there right okay also is seeing
a report out there that Jed allegedly
went on the show with a very recent
girlfriend I'm working on this I don't
have details and specifics confirmed on
my own so I don't want to judge on it
too hard I just will say this I think
this happens a lot a lot more than
people think Jed was already honest with
Hanna about going on the show for his
music platform and maybe you know
there's still like so much of the season
left maybe he's honest with her about
that at some point and it comes up so
I'm not judging hard yet I just
interviewed Devin on et live this
morning shameless plug check it out and
he said that Jed is the guy who was like
the nicest most genuine guy in the house
so Heidi Kok blog
Blagh Blagh JC you are here because you
are a beautiful person inside and out
just tell us how you treat women just
give us some hope
be grateful look for the best in them
you know allow them to see you allow
them to share with you you don't I don't
need to be a hero I don't need to prove
myself I Know Who I am and that reflects
and the person I get to go out with and
that's the thing it's all about
gratitude guys and just showing
appreciation time after time
you